this machine was destined for russia but
under current conditions it won't be
delivered
its export has been prohibited for fear
it could be used for military purposes
the machine is used to produce parts for
trucks
but as russian customers could also use
it to produce military equipment
the german company that manufactures it
is not allowed to ship it
and this is just the beginning
we haven't had any orders at all
recently we're still in negotiations
with our russian partners on several
projects but of course it's extremely
difficult
the company based in saxony used to sell
about a quarter of all its machines to
russia
the export ban is also a big problem for
russian firms
they have no idea whether they'll be
able to get the machines they need
whether their german suppliers will be
allowed to deliver them
it throws up very important questions
concerning reliability
our russian customers simply can't
depend on us at the moment
the region around chemnitz is an
important center of mechanical
engineering
when it was part of former east germany
it delivered supplies to companies in
the soviet union
the good business relationships with the
former soviet states continued after the
fall of the berlin wall
this producer of drilling machines has
obtained permission to supply one of its
russian customers after he obtained a
special export license
an additional problem is that nowadays
in russia there are a lot of big
companies with several subsidiaries and
in many cases one or the other of these
subsidiaries makes military equipment
proving that isn't actually the case
with particular companies has become
extremely difficult
these machines are used to produce
electric engines
their use is unambiguous
despite that the company has received no
new orders for them
russian customers are holding back
at the moment we're not in a position to
cultivate those business relationships
so that they develop into long-term
commitments
we hope the situation doesn't last too
long
then perhaps we'll be able to repair our
damaged customer relations
but if it goes on for a long time and
our customers manage to find new supply
channels that suit them it'll be
difficult to get them back
many jobs in chemnitz depend on the
success of the mechanical engineering
sector so local people are following
political developments between the eu
and russia with great concern
a survey done by germany's chamber of
industry and commerce confirms that one
in ten companies is directly affected by
the economic sanctions
it will be reflected in job losses and
difficult situations for businesses
some companies have already applied for
government schemes which allow them to
reduce working hours
other businesses have applied for state
bank guarantees to help them get
bridging loans the highest
that shows us this is not something that
could be a problem in the future
it's a crisis right here and now
as long as the sanctions remain in place
the situation will get worse
the biggest worry of many companies is
that the eu trade sanctions could be
made even more comprehensive
if that happens it'll be almost
impossible for them to sell any machines
to russian customers at all